[Music]
the idea of what the Super Smash
Brothers games are and what they can be
has been different things during the
series is 20 year history what began as
an accessible multiplayer game also
became a highly competitive one-on-one
game but it's also been noted for having
a comprehensive single-player adventure
as well as becoming a sort of virtual
museum catalog exhibiting knowledge and
audio-visual artifacts from the
histories of its increasingly diverse
crossover cast ultimate embraces all
these aspects and each has been notably
refined added to and improved for the
better everyone and basically everything
from previous games is here all existing
characters nearly all existing stages
along with the flexibility to play and
enjoy those things in different ways
Super Smash Brothers ultimate is a
comprehensive considered and charming
package that build on an already strong
and enduring fighting system
if you've ever spent time with a smash
game then you likely have a good idea of
how ultimate works competing players
deal damage to their opponents in order
to more easily knock them off the stage
the controls remain relatively
approachable for a competitive combat
game three different buttons in tandem
with basic directional movements are all
you need to access a character's variety
of attacks and special abilities there
are a large variety of items and
power-ups to mix things up if you want
to and interesting dynamic stages to
fight on also if you want to you can
find complexities past this of course
once you quickly experience the breadth
of a character's skill set it allows you
to begin thinking about the nuances of a
fight again if you want to thinking
about optimal positioning figuring out
what attacks can easily combo off
another working out with the best move
that each situation is and playing mind
games with your human opponents can
quickly become considerations and the
allure of smash as a fighting game is
how easy it is to reach that stage
[Music]
complexity also comes with the wide
variety of techniques afforded by
ultimate staggeringly large roster of
over 70 characters smashes continuing
accessibility is a fortunate trait in
this regard because once you understand
the basic idea of how to control a
character many of the barriers to trying
out a completely new one are gone every
fighter who has appeared in the previous
four smash games is here along with some
brand new ones in the presence of so
many diverse and unorthodox styles to
both wheels and compete against is just
as attractive as the presence of the
characters themselves in fact it's still
astounding that a game featuring
characters from Mario Brothers Sonic the
Hedgehog
pac-man Metal Gear Solid Final Fantasy
and Street Fighter all interacting with
each other actually exists on a more
technical level ultimate makes a number
of under-the-hood alterations that atlas
early stage seemed like positive changes
that make Smashville noticeably faster
and more exciting to both watch and play
characters take more damage in
one-on-one fights continuous dodging is
punished with increased vulnerability
fighters can perform any ground-based
attack including smash moves immediately
out of a running state and short hop
aerial attacks previously a moderately
demanding technique can be easily
performed by pressing two buttons
simultaneously refinements like these
might go unnoticed by most but they help
define ultimate score gameplay as a
tangible evolution of the series's core
mechanics a number of ultimate small
superficial changes also helped smashes
general quality of life experience to
some making a more readable game
additions to the UI communicate
previously hidden elements a simple
radar helps keep track of characters off
screen and a slow-motion zoom in visual
effect when critical hits connect and
make these moments more exciting to
watch other changes help streamline the
core multiplayer experience and add
compelling options match rules can now
be predefined with a swather modifiers
and saved for quick selection later
stage selection occurs before character
selection now so you can make more
informed decisions on which fighter to
use on top of a built in tournament
bracket mode ultimate also features a
number of additional smash styles super
sudden death returns as does custom
smash which allows you to create matches
with wacky modifiers squad strike is a
personal favorite which allows you to
play 3b3 or five-on-five tag team
battles and smash down is a
right engaging mode that makes the most
of the games large character roster by
disqualifying characters that have
already been used as a series of matches
continues challenging your ability to do
well with characters who might not be
familiar with the most significant
addition to ultimate however lies in its
single-player content ultimate once
again features a classic mode where each
individual fighter has their own unique
ladder of opponents to defeat but the
bigger deal is world of light ultimate
surprisingly substantial RPG style
campaign
it's a convoluted setup beginning as
Kirby you go on a long journey
throughout a huge world map to rescue
smattered other fighters who have all
internet Li been cloned in large numbers
from the big bads control along the way
you'll do battle with spirits characters
hailing from other video games that
while not directly engaging in combat of
taking control of clones altered them in
their images and unleash them on you
though there's some light puzzling the
world is naturally filled with hundreds
upon hundreds of fights there are over
1200 spirit characters and the vast
majority have their own unique battle
stages that use the game's match
variables to represent their essence it
may seem like a tenuous idea at first
but these fights are incredibly
entertaining it's hard not to appreciate
the creativity of using smashes assets
to represent a thousand different
characters if I knew the character that
was being represented I often found
myself thinking about how clever their
spirit battle was and there are some
really good ones in here defeating a
spirit will add it to your collection
and spirits also act as world of light
RPG system there are two types of spirit
primary and support primary spirits have
their own power number and can be
leveled up through various means to help
make your actual fighter stronger
primary spirits also have one of four
associated classes which determine
combat effectiveness in a
rock-scissors-paper style system these
are both major considerations to take
into account before a battle and making
sure you're not going into a fight at a
massive disadvantage adds a nice
dimension to the amusing
unpredictability of this mode which also
needs to take into account are the
modifiers that might be enabled on each
stage which is where support spirits
come in these can be attached to primary
spirits in a limited quantity and can
mitigate the effect of things like
poisonous flaws pitch-black stages
reversed controls or they can simply
buff certain attacks there are a few
spirit fights that can be frustrating
however stages that are 1 versus 4 pylon
are downright annoying despite how well
equipped you might be as our stages
where you compete against powerful
assist trophies on the flip side once
you find yourself towards the end of the
campaign there are certain loadouts that
can trivialize most stages earning you
victory in less than a second regardless
there's a compulsive quality to
collecting spirits and it's not just
because they might make you stronger
it's exciting to see which obscure
character you might run into next and
see how the game interprets them in a
spirit battle
[Music]
there's also just a superficial joy to
collecting your favorite characters even
though these collectibles lack the
frills of previous smash games some hubs
in the wall of light map are also themed
around certain games and bundle related
spirits together to great effect and
despite the dramatic overtones of wallop
spirits set up the imagines that you
find within it feel like a nice
commemoration of the games and
characters without feeling like a
pandering nostalgia play one of the most
rewarding and Marge's of all though lies
in ultimate huge library of video game
music
over 800 tracks which include originals
as well as fantastic new arrangements
can all be set as stage soundtracks as
well as enjoyed through the game's music
player now there is one significant
struggle that ultimate comes up against
which lies in the nature of the console
itself playing smash ultimate in the
switches handheld mode is simply not a
great experience in situations where
there are more than two characters on
screen the view of the action often
becomes too wide making the fight is too
small to see properly and it can be
difficult to tell what you or your
opponent is doing the game's penchant
with flashy special effects and busy
colorful stages doesn't help things at
all and unless you're playing a
one-on-one match you'll likely suffer
some blameless losses this is a
situational disadvantage and may not
affect all players but it puts a damper
on the idea of smash on the go the need
to unlock characters also has the
potential to be an initial annoyance
especially if your goal is to jump
straight into multiplayer and start
learning one of the six brand new
characters in my time with the game I
split my attention between playing wall
of light we're rescuing characters
unlocks them everywhere and multiplayer
matches where the constant drip-feed of
new challenger opportunities which you
can easily retry if you fail came pretty
regularly I naturally unlocks the entire
roster in roughly 10 hours of playtime
but your mileage may vary
your mileage may also vary in ultimate
online mode where the experience of
competing against others was
inconsistent during the 200-plus matches
we played ultimate matches you with
players from your region but continues
to use peer-to-peer style connectivity
which means the quality of the
experience relies primarily on the
strength of each plays internet
connection a bad connection from any
player can result in a noticeable input
delay stuttering and even freezing as
the game tries to deal with latency
issues things have the greatest
potential to go bad during 4 player
matches where there's a greater chance
of finding a weak link there's some
blame to be put on the console itself
because the switch only has the
capabilities for Wi-Fi networking you
can invest in an optional USB LAN
adapter to make sure your own connection
is stable but because of the
peer-to-peer nature I found that the
experience was just as inconsistent you
can totally get lucky of course I would
regularly enjoy sessions filled with
smooth matches but regardless laggy
matches on exactly a rare occurrence
it's also worth noting that you're
required to have a paid subscription to
Nintendo's switch online service to be
able to play online at all so the sub
optimal performance of the mode is
disappointing network performance aside
Ultimates online mode does have an
interesting way to cater to the large
variety of ways to play Smash Brothers
you can create public or private arenas
for friends and strangers which serve as
personal rooms to dictate specific rule
sets but the primary mode is quick play
where you're matched against people of a
similar skill level to you quick play
has an option where you can set your
preferred rule set things like the
number of players item availability and
wind conditions and it'll try and match
you up with someone with similar
preferences
however ultimate also prioritizes
getting you into a match in under a
minute which is great but sometimes
means that you might find yourself
playing a completely different style of
match in my experience I found that
there are enough people who wanted to
play with my roll set which is
one-on-one 3 stock 6 minutes no items
Omega sages only and I would find myself
in these kinds of matches or at least a
very close approximation the majority of
the time
getting thrown into the occasional
four-player free-for-all felt like a
nice refreshing change of pace to me but
depending on how flexible you are as a
player this can be a turn-off but like
so much of ultimate its multitude of
options in styles of play doesn't
necessarily mean that all of them will
suit every player an inconsistent online
mode and situational Downers don't stop
Super Smash Brothers ultimate from
shining as a flexible multiplayer game
that can be as freewheeling or as firm
as you want it to be it's entertaining
single-player content helps keep the
game rich with interesting things to do
as well as bolstering its spirit of
loving a march to the games that have
graced Nintendo's consoles Ultimates
diverse content is compelling it's
strong mechanics are refined and the
encompassing collection is simply superb
[Music]